italic who's the founder of ethereum is
being really apologetic about Sam
bankman freed like he's not going hard
on him Sam backman for his tweets I'm
sorry vitalik retweets it he's like we
should all be a bit kinder to him no the
guy just stole billions from people so
vitalik is like being very sympathetic
to these people they've also just moved
from proof of work to proof of stake I
don't know how technical you are but
proof of stake is like really championed
by those of the world economic forum and
because of the energy crisis if the
world economic Forum are excited about
proof of stake then I'm not excited
about proof of stake that's just a red
flag at this point nothing that has come
out of what they've done or what they've
said is good is legitimate everything
that surrounds them is just dark and bad
in my opinion and then also like proof
of stake is far more centralized just
because if you have a big Escape then
you have more control and that's like
the current system that we're in